two roads diverged in a wood and i
i took the one less traveled by and that
has made all the difference
no i love robert frost is that his
anthology of poetry
nope an economics book economics
oh we're talking about opportunity costs
aren't we
why have you got something better to do
[Music]
vic is a food server at an upscale
restaurant he gets a call from his
friend ben
who has an extra ticket to the my
chemical romance reunion tour
though ben paid 60 for the ticket he's
willing to sell it to vic
for 40. since it's his second favorite
band vic would happily pay
twice that so he gets someone to cover
his shift and they split an uber to the
concert
unfortunately vic ends up missing almost
half the show waiting in the beer line
where he spends another 20 and the seats
aren't even that great
as he cranes his neck to see the stage
vic can't help but calculate
how much this mediocre night cost him
before you bother doing the math you
might notice there's something missing
the work shift vic gave up to go to the
concert
since he typically makes about 150 in
wages and tips on a friday night
he would actually be 220 richer if he
had skipped the concert and gone to work
instead
this is an example of what economists
call opportunity cost
which is typically defined as the
benefit that is missed or given up by
choosing
one alternative over another and it
doesn't just apply to money
if you decide to eat at a chinese
restaurant instead of a mexican one
you might enjoy the kung pao chicken but
it's at the cost of not enjoying a plate
of enchiladas
life is full of such forks in the road
you and your wallet
can't be in two places at one time so
we're constantly faced with decisions
about where to put
our time and money the concept of
opportunity cost
encourages you to look far down both
paths and compare
all the ramifications of each option
this may seem like common sense to you
but you'd be surprised how often it's
overlooked when making financial
decisions
for example angela is deciding whether
or not to take out loans to go to
college
she does some research and finds that
the median yearly income gap between
high school and college graduates is
around seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars
even if her loan payments are seven
thousand dollars a year
well above average she'd still be way
ahead she decides to take out the loans
while cleaning out his parents cellar
ted finds an old bottle of wine
and his parents let him keep it for his
trouble it turns out to be a pretty
expensive vintage so that night ted and
his boyfriend
enjoy a fancy bottle of cabernet with
their dinner for free
pamela is looking for a place to rent
and finds a great deal on a nice house
with a
big backyard the catch it's outside the
public transportation system so she'll
have to lease a car to commute to work
but she calculates that even including
car payments gas and insurance
she'll still pay less than if she lived
downtown in each of these cases the
decision makers have failed to properly
weigh
the opportunity costs of their choices
if angela goes to college
she may make more money down the road
but she will miss out on four years of
salary and job experience
that she would have gotten with a
full-time job that cab may seem free to
ted
but it's actually costing him a hundred
dollars not to sell it
and pamela has overlooked the amount of
time she'll spend in the car
which she could otherwise use to relax
pursue hobbies or
make more money to be clear that doesn't
mean their decisions were necessarily
wrong just that they didn't have a full
picture
of what they were giving up opportunity
costs are especially relevant
to people in business or government
where shareholders and political
opponents are more than happy to imagine
how that money could have been better
used
if an executive wants to spend 10
million
on a marketing campaign he has to show
that not only will it return a profit
but that it will return more of a profit
than any
other use of that money like renovating
a factory or developing a new product
if a city council wants to build a rec
center it's not enough to say
it will benefit the community it has to
create a
larger benefit than if the money were
used for any other purpose like
education or housing opportunity costs
are also a
key concept behind specialization which
means
focusing on a smaller scope of
production to increase efficiency
for instance elon owns two factories
factory a can produce 50 electric cars
in one day and factory b
can produce 40. but if they switch
production
over to his new cyber truck both
factories have the same daily output
20. this means that every cyber truck
factory a makes
comes at an opportunity cost of 2.5
electric cars
not made elon decides to have factory b
produce all his cyber trucks because the
opportunity cost
is lower even if you're not an auto
executive or a city council member
taking a moment to weigh opportunity
costs before a decision
will make you a more competent cfo of
your own life
it's also a good reminder that money is
fungible
every dollar you spend in one place
could theoretically be spent
anywhere else but it's important to
remember that opportunity costs refer to
all benefits not just financial ones
the experience of college life the
comfort of a spacious house
and the emotional satisfaction of
treating yourself are hard to put on a
balance sheet
but the benefits are no less real even
vic had no way of knowing that night
would be a bust
if he had skipped the show and worked
his shift instead
he might have ended up kicking himself
over the opportunity cost of missing
what he imagined
to be the greatest concert of all time
you can see how thinking
too much about opportunity costs can
send you down a rabbit hole of infinite
possibilities and regrets
you can go crazy trying to weigh every
conceivable pro and con
of every conceivable decision it's good
to remember
that big life decisions are often more
like forks in the road than a vast
infinite ocean you're usually only
deciding between a manageable number of
options and it's always best
to face forward not second guess where
you've been
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
you